Secondly, our new mantra: small is sexy.
We want space efficiency.
We want things that are designed for how they're used the vast majority of the time, not that rare event.
Why have a six-burner stove when you rarely use three?
So we want things that nest, we want things that stack, and we want it digitized.
You can take paperwork, books, movies, and you can make it disappear, it's magic.
Finally, we want multifunctional spaces and housewares,...
...a sink combined with a toilet, a dining table becomes a bed same space,...
...a little side table stretches out to seat 10.
In a winning LifeEdited scheme in a render here,...
...we combine a moving wall with transformer furniture to get a lot out of the space.
Look at the coffee table, it grows in height and width to seat 10.
My office folds away, easily hidden.
My bed just pops out of the wall with two fingers.
Guests?
Move the moving wall, have some fold-down guest beds.
And of course, my own movie theater.
So, I'm not saying that we all need to live in 420 square feet.
But consider the benefits of an edited life.
Go from 3,000 to 2,000, from 1,500 to 1,000.
Most of us, maybe all of us, are here pretty happily for a bunch of days with a couple of bags,...
...maybe a small space, a hotel room.
So, when you go home and you walk through your front door, take a second and ask yourselves,...
..."Could I do with a little life editing?
Would that give me a little more freedom?
Maybe a little more time?"
What's in the box?
It doesn't really matter.
I know I don't need it.
What's in yours?
Maybe, just maybe, less might equal more.
So let's make room for the good stuff.
Thank you.